- Alright, you don't want to
miss anything on social media
that can make you smile, alright?
We need smiles.
Don't worry, I've got you covered.
This is What I'm Liking.
(upbeat music)
A good Charcuterie Board
takes more than just laying
out some meats and cheeses.
It's an art form people.
Also, how you say it,
because I was told, I say
it wrong, Charcuterie.
Apparently, it's Charcuterie.
Some will say Charcuterie, for you.
Tiffany in Brooklyn has mastered the art,
So when she lost her corporate
job during the pandemic,
she had a light-bulb moment.
Her family is obsessed
with her Charcuterie Boards
complete without using no meat or cheese,
locally sourced fruits,
jam, nuts and more.
So, she decided to make her
signature spread in boxes
and sell them for New Yorkers
to enjoy those delicious,
and people are literally eating them up.
Get it.
We know you do.
From Cheese & Things,
let's say hi to Tiffany,
who watches the show on NBC 4 New York.
What's up?
(crowd cheering)
- Hi Kelly
- [Kelly Clarkson] Hello
So, what made you want to do this?
- Oh my gosh!
Good question.
Thank you so much for having me on.
So I lost my job like a lot
of people within the pandemic,
and so, I had a lot of time on my hands.
I needed somewhere to
channel my creativity,
and so a light bulb went off,
and I said, do your boards.
I come from a very large
West Indian family,
Jamaican to be exact,
and so my brother is a trained chef,
and the only thing that he would let me do
was the Charcuterie Boards.
and so it just came to me,
just put your boards in a box.
We were in the middle of a pandemic,
and it just made total sense.
- It does and you can send
one right on over to my house.
I love a Charcuterie Board.
That was over a year ago though,
so how is business going right now?
- Oh my gosh!
It's been amazing.
It's blowing my mind
to be perfectly honest.
- Where?
- It's within New York,
it's very difficult to social distance,
and so with the idea of
going from board to box,
we developed a solo box,
and so it's for individual consumption.
And so, as New Yorkers,
we're taking to the streets
and taking to the parks.
They still have that communal aspect,
but still being safe.
And so what's next for me
is really to just be the edible
arrangements of Charcuterie.
- Oh my gosh!
It sounds amazing.
Thank you, Tiffany.
I'm liking your post right now.
It looks so good.
That's not all.
Our season long partner Pilot Pen.
The go-to pen of the Kelly Clarkson show
wants to honor ultimate
overachievers just like you.
So they'll be using their G2 gel ink pen
to write you a check for a $1000.
How's that sound?
(crowd cheering)
- Oh my gosh!
Thank you
- Yes.
That will make one hell
of a Charcuterie Board.